hey there I'm Jason Goss and you're
listening to think again
a big fing podcast since 2008 big think
has been bringing you big ideas in
little concentrated doses from some of
the most creative thinkers around on
think again we step outside of our
comfort zone surprising our guests send
me your host with unexpected clips from
big things archives ideas that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss today I'm very very happy to be
joined by actor writer and director
Alton Brown when you say that again it's
not an it out I'm not an actor as far as
I know what they call you IMDB and they
do yeah yeah it probably shouldn't well
I mean you did voice on The Simpsons
who's on The Simpsons I've done voice
work on Disney projects that's where I'm
going today all right so the quick
writer and director Alton Brown a living
legend in food TV and you may not be
aware that he was the cinematographer
for the video for REM is the one I love
when he was a film student he was the
creator and host of the show good eats
would transfer 14 seasons on 14 years 14
I don't we don't even know how many
seasons it was okay countless seasons
and horsemen long amazing year on Food
Network and has a 9 out of 10 rating on
IMDB which is basically unheard of
Casablanca by contrast is 8.6
he's also known as the host of Iron Chef
America cutthroat kitchen and feasting
on asphalt he's the author of many books
and his latest book is everyday cook one
word in which he shares his favorite
personal recipes including the amazing
looking breakfast part menara which I
will be making forthwith which makes
pasta for breakfast not only okay but it
seems to me
mandatory welcome to think again Alton
thank you very much no I was great I had
a longer introduction means you they're
getting something done it so okay I have
a bunch of questions for you let's start
with um you know your book every
cook the tagline is this time it's
personal because these are these are
recipes you've created yes yeah and I
wondered whether there are any
interesting or fun or quirky or strange
stories behind any specific resident
they all look amazing
I want to make that bourbon bread
pudding ASAP
the carbonara um interesting stories you
know I think that whenever you're trying
to paint a self-portrait you have to
question some of the things that you do
and I think that you know you take your
food your kind of everyday food and try
to translate it into a book worthy
recipe it's always an illuminating
activity I didn't realize how much I
cooked things with with alcohol III III
have to take a real close look on myself
I didn't realize wow really I'm drinking
a great deal and how really bad I am at
certain things such as well oddly enough
you know what the most frustrating
recipe in this book it was something
that it's like well I do this every day
so it's gonna be easy to write down and
get right and we started testing it it
was actually working out the procedure
for cold brew coffee because you realize
that people's tastes become far more
challenging you know that's a few years
ago you guys said oh here's cold brew
right people have said oh okay now you
say well here's cold brew and they're
like oh well you know the co brewed over
Bob Leblon this was so much more
knowledgeable and their their tastes are
so much more developed and they're picky
about things like that so I realized
that oh my god I haven't tested this
enough it's not working 100% of the time
and gosh darn it you know I really need
to make sure that these notes are coming
out of this and we had to do it over and
over and over and over for something
that I thought was going to be a
throwaway Punk shot easily done that's
really interesting yeah I mean I think
when I think about kind of the history
of food entertainment I think you know
these trends come up you suddenly
everyone salt is the thing or what
but I guess also there is this thing of
people getting more and more
sophisticated yes and then so then let's
consumers as consumers and and in that
go ahead no no no please it's a big it's
a big deal because you know people now
understand oh gee that's Spanish saffron
in there isn't it you know you're like
oh my gosh we are so good at grocery
shopping we are so knowledgeable as
eaters even people that can't cook which
is interesting it's like someone can't
scramble eggs but can you know make
critical analysis of caramel you know
right and so it's it's an interesting
time to be writing about food and
certainly developing recipes because
expectations are high it says with a
book like this it's not that I'm worried
that people won't have success with the
recipes instead they'll think less of me
because of how I eat that's the things
like this for the first time I'm writing
a book that's actually food that I eat
I'm not trying to prove anything I'm not
riding for sign this is just my food and
I'm afraid people are gonna look at it
and say well gee you're kind of that's
actually now that you're right is
everything as we thought you were I mean
in in as much as that yeah I'm not
making spherification x' and you know
flavored stuff like that is just food
right although I have to say like you
know that's refreshing as well and
probably everyone is always going to be
interested in food in one form or
another like there's you can't become
endlessly increasingly sophisticated
there comes a point with any art or
science well I don't know about science
but with any art at least where I think
there has to be a kind of backlash
towards simplicity sometimes and people
saying you know what like how do we make
a good hamburger you know I honestly I
just want well there's a level to where
you can only fuss with something right
to where you just say damn dude it's
just a hamburger oh okay I mean lighten
up and you know there's a hamburger in
my book and and I'm the only reason I'm
worried about it is that when I make
hamburgers for myself I make them in a
way that I never would have admitted
I make them I actually deep-fry the
things and if you do it right it makes a
delightful burger that's not greasy but
I I would have been afraid to share that
yeah even a few years ago you know I
said we were horrified when they learned
that about deep-fried turkeys but now it
seems to be like people are purchasing
$700 turkey deep fryers why they're
doing that I have because you can do
that at a hardware store for about 50
bucks but yeah they want to do that they
can yeah I mean if there's any gadget to
geek out on people well a couple other
things so you have a stage show Alton
Brown live it's coming to your science
yeah the science that's my second road
show the big difference with this one is
that we're playing Broadway yeah and in
November which is a little bit just a
little wee bit terrifying yeah you're
gonna be at the Barrymore band at the
bear more only eight performances but
it's still Broadway and you know you can
play so we've already toured this
particular show for seven weeks in the
spring we're changing it up a little bit
for Thanksgiving but you know you can
play a lot of houses and and you'll
still be terrified by Broadway I'm sure
yeah so intimidating yeah he's like
Hamilton's right over there you know I
get throw a rock and hit that at least
yeah way too timid yeah so but you've
got puppets and Muppets they're fire
there's no there's not fire I know why
you can't theater people don't like fire
yeah in that effect coming up with with
a big culinary variety show that's
fireless has been the constant issue
because this is our second full show
because he is a big deal you know
yeah so it's like when we did our first
show the Edible inevitable tour we built
a gigantic Easy Bake Oven out of lights
eight feet tall twelve feet long it
generated 1 million 26,000 lumens of
light and would cook a large pizza in
about four minutes and it was very
visual and we could do it because was
lice no fire right the way that I do my
shows is the first act has always got a
giant demo that's cold and the other one
is always heat so yeah interesting
that's all I'll say
asterisk there like it is the great
regret of my childhood and I never had
an easy bake oven because they were
marketed all girly and so my parents
there is a song there's a song on the CD
coming up called easy-bake and it's a
very angry Punk song about how I was not
allowed to have one and how when I asked
Santa for what he had told me they were
for girls and there's a whole section
about that and then I finally saved
enough money to get my own damn Easy
Bake Oven also I've been getting back
ever since they're still making them
yeah they do their grotesquely
underpowered now and they're very
difficult to hack so they still pink
because they were purple now okay
because yeah yeah it's a prince
awesome well I'm so glad I did there is
a funk song about to happen yeah it's
kind of a folk Punk song live I don't
even know if that's a thing but acoustic
I guess it is now and actually the last
thing I want to say on the stage show
front is that I've had an idea for many
years that maybe now we have an
opportunity maybe this will actually
take flight as a result of this
conversation Benihana the music oh
absolutely people I will back that I
will back Benihana the musical right now
yeah let me get my checkbook I really I
mean you probably need fire to make it
cool see that's the problem
fire and theaters don't mix I'm getting
insurance my first show I had one part
of show I lit a Zippo lighter okay and
if I in there were several cities
especially in California or if I lit the
Zippo lighter I had to have three
firemen on staff onstage it's kind of
like really for a Zippo lighter but
apparently in the past some theaters
have burned down with a lot of people
inside that's why we have video we do
big fire things on video still there
must be some way to make it work for
Benihana the musical I think there is
it's just a matter of we got it we got
to fake the fire fooling sort of yeah
flapping silk or something theater craft
yeah all right well Alton this is us to
the second part of the show in which we
discussed surprise concepts but now if
they surprise you and they surprise me
where do they come from well so the
here's the deal yeah so big thing does
video we have like 10,000 little clips
of interviews dating back to 2008 right
with just about everyone physicists
whatever you know they're chosen by the
producers and they could be on three
different subjects or they might have
decide
to make your life too easy and it's all
David Chang or something but let's see
let's see what we get
go for it all right the first one is
drew Ramsey who is a nutritional
psychiatrist on diet and depression I'm
depressed whenever I go on a diet I can
confirm this okay yes there is a
relationship between dieting and
oppressive case closed conversation over
for about 10 years we've had very strong
correlational data showing that for
example when you eat poorly your risk of
depression and illnesses like depression
just go up 70 80 % and when you eat a
more traditional diet like a
Mediterranean diet or a Japanese diet
your risk of an illness like depression
can go down by as much as 50 percent so
that's now led to the first clinical
trial that that is just being reported
showing that a Mediterranean diet is
augmented with some red meat actually
can treat clinical depression major
depressive disorder and it's a very
exciting moment for nutritional
psychiatry it's a time when we have more
science that tells us food should really
be part of the conversation when it
comes to our mental health we think
about a lot of illnesses when we eat
heart disease cancer diabetes and it's
always struck me that really the illness
you should be worried about other organ
you should be worried about when you're
eating is your brain because that is by
far your biggest asset it consumes more
of your energy and your food than any
other organ you have and so focusing on
the nutrients your brain needs guides
you to a slightly different set of foods
than if you focus on just things like
calories or saturated fat or preventing
something like cancer and so it's an
exciting moment as the data begins to
catch up with with common sense
well first stop dude there's there's
absolutely no way to deny the fact that
what we put into our mouths affect our
mental health that is absolutely there's
nothing he said is surprising no nothing
in that message is surprising and I
believe that from on a few levels I
believe it on a on a chemical level
right the the quality and amount of
specific nutrients let's face it we
evolved on this planet you know because
we knew what to pick up and eat and what
to put down you know and if you ate the
wrong stuff you died it's part of
evolution and we can only really be what
we eat on a strictly chemical level got
it absolutely understand that however I
would also argue that the experiential
part of how we absorb food matters as
well I would hazard a guess I do not
have data to support that
but I would imagine that if we took the
same diet that was very shall we say
mental health balanced for you know the
anti depression diet or whatever and and
I we you and I both did that diet and
you ate alone everyday in an airport
terminal and I ate with a great big
Jewish family that our mental health
that we would extract from that would be
very very different Jewish family that's
been provided what everybody because I
because I'm not actually but I love
eating with you and I also haven't
really liked the food
but we would we would have very very
different outcomes right even though we
had the same positive nutrients because
the the actual active how we eat and
where we eat in the environment we
didn't and the time that we eat and what
we're listening to talking to all of
that also affects mental health so it's
great to be able to look at this at a
nutritive level but we have to see the
baddest part of a of a much larger
cultural issue do you find personally
that in your busy entertainment life are
you happy with how and where you eat no
no would you lie am currently depressed
no it's true
depression is not alien to me I was
treated for it once and I was in
culinary school number one when I get
fat I get depressed because I looked on
being can't fit in my clothes too I do
believe that simply the kinds of food
you eat can lead you in a depression but
I also eat alone too often I ate on the
go too often and I eat right now
currently too much food that's prepared
for me by people I do not know as
opposed to by someone who loves me right
it's just a short list or myself so I
think that the preparation of food by
your own hands or in a family situation
that's a factor where you eat it how you
eat it that's a factor so yeah right now
I'm not I'm not in a great place because
the work that I do in the way that I
travel and my own lack of discipline and
adoration for bourbon yeah yeah alcohol
should be very high up on the list of
foods
well you know it for me it's not that
the alcohol causes depression it's it
when I drink I tend to eat badly because
you know the first thing you get is fats
salts the first thing that goes you know
I'm a pilot one of the first things that
they you know they teach you when
they're talking about alcohol and flying
is you know the first thing that goes is
your judgment first thing that goes is
your judgment ordinarily I would need
this bag of potato chips right but I've
had to two drinks oh my god I'm gonna
eat the bag of tater chips why because
my judgments gone but you know I think
there's also a physiological thing about
that which I don't actually understand
but you know the reason why brunches
tend to be sort of fatty and salty and
people are hung over like they you know
they don't necessarily like that lack of
judgment from the night before isn't
necessarily still there it's more like
you crave those things well I think
there's a physical thing going on there
as well because you know when your body
is trying to get off of a hangover which
is essentially having been poisoned a
certain things really work well right
nothing can get me over a hangover a
quicker than a good greasy order of
french fries because the grease
stabilizes you know and changes what the
liver is doing and kind of shifts the
attention and so it's sort of like if
you've been horribly injured in one leg
biting biting your arm yeah or have you
been snake bit over here badly cut the
other side actually it's exactly the
opposite of that but it sounds good it
does sound good yeah okay well shall we
see what the next surprise video son no
no no this one is Ethan Hawke the actor
talking about success by small
achievable goals
I have thrived on one simple idea which
is placing achievable goals in front of
you I never would give myself a goal
like writing a novel I do well by saying
I'm going to try and write everyday for
10 days this is one you know I remember
when I was first starting to teach
myself to write so I would say I'm gonna
go away for 10 days I'll go on a 10-day
retreat and I'll write every day for 10
days with the goal of one short story
I'm gonna come back with one short story
I can handle my friends and usually
those simple actions give you confidence
I didn't decide that I wanted to direct
films I told myself that I was gonna
direct a short film something that I
could afford I took the money I made
from Dead Poets Society and I made a
short film I've got a graphic novel
coming out that's kind of weird you know
for an actor to do and I made a
documentary last year I wrote a
children's book to a lot of people that
strikes them as weird or they can accuse
me of being a dilettante or something
like that
right but I believe in cultivating the
attitude of a student at all times you
know if all I did was act since I was 13
I could do that but it doesn't help me
become a better actor but you have to
make it you know because failing is
depressing and it makes you lose steam
and whereas if you say like I don't have
to direct a movie by next year anything
like that but I will have a first draft
or I'll die and okay and very often you
can get done soon
I he said two things yeah one he talked
about working outside of your comfort
zone right I could not agree more
you only define yourself by looking out
on the dark edges of the map you know I
just came out of recording a CD with
music that I'd written with me actually
having a sing and play the instruments
and was that fine yeah doesn't matter
I'm kidding
what did that say me out of my comfort
zone yeah it took me out of my comfort
zone too when I you know designed a
stage show that required me to play an
electric guitar which by the way I did
not know how to play when I started but
I knew that if I was going to do a
variety show there had to be music so I
had to learn to do these things and I
had to put myself outside the comfort
zone and risk ridicule and risk failure
so that's kind of opposed to what his
initial thesis is which is set up small
achievable goals small achievable goals
are boring and typically was it to steam
it was of name Burum the guy that was
the architect that built the the World's
Fair in Chicago he's very well known for
saying make no small plans so make no
small plans and and so I believe that
you know if you set yourself a bunch of
little bitty achievable goals what you
will have with when you die is a very
small achievable life okay I have can I
can interject sure so I think you're I
think that's generally right but I think
with very large goals maybe breaking
them down into smaller achievable goals
so don't stick yourself up you know
don't say oh my gosh I'm going to by
this time next year I will have made
blah blah blah you got to know you know
Dirty Harry said a man has got to know
his limitations
you've got to know your limitations you
got to know what is reasonable but if
you make it comfortable like okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna go on a retreat for 10
days and write a short story for my
friends what the really really
that's what you're gonna do with 10 days
no you go to an or retreat for 10 days
and write something for yourself I'm
sorry there's a balance between am I
gonna be safe you know it's that balance
of risk and if you're too risk-averse
you never get anything done
anytime that I've achieved anything that
made me respect myself at all there was
a much higher probability of failure
than success you find yourself in that
in that nook and that shadowy land
between what I know I can do what I'm
pretty sure I can do and what I have no
freaking idea what I can do and if all
of my goals are set for the things I
don't know then odds are I'm just gonna
have a life of disappointment failure if
I do everything within that realm of I
can do this this is an achievable goal
then I will never have known what would
have happened if I'd stretched so he's
right and he's wrong I think you've got
that did a successful I'm gonna call it
successful but but a life of interesting
work you have to know when to set up
achievable goals and when to reach way
outside the comfort zone and it's
finding that balance that's the real art
of creative life is to know to find and
define that dark gray area between those
two things and find out how to live in
that that area yeah I was gonna ask you
like don't you think it also comes down
a little bit to your own knowing your
own personal psychology and kind of what
is the line for you between taking a
risk that's gonna advance you creatively
and trauma that's gonna make you shut
down for the rest of your life I mean
I'm not saying like that you should
always be cautious but I feel like
people grow at different rates and in
different ways sure they do and you can
have yourself a really nice successful
profitable career wisely playing it safe
by by figuring out exactly where the
borders of your safety net are and never
going past them there are a lot of
people that do that and you know what if
they're happy with that fantastic
no I'm serious I'm not being sarcastic
but then there are people that want to
see you know that our personal Maps have
the little drawing with the thing that
says you know beyond here be dragons
right and there are those of us that
want to see the Dragons yeah and maybe
tame a dragon maybe get our asses kicked
by a dragon that's the spark man that's
the stuff that makes life like I don't
know if I can do this I don't know I
know that I won't quit I know that I
won't give up until I really need to one
of my few personal attributes that is
useful to me
is I'm a fantastically good self editor
I have never done anything that sucked
that I didn't know sucked first and I
know when I can look at my own ideas and
say oh my god that is so bad and and
I'll come right up next to it I will
play chicken with that I will get right
up close but I'll always know when to
veer off and and hopefully that keeps me
from becoming ridiculous that's hard
yeah that's me I may be completely wrong
about this by the way you know only I
don't I don't know when we'll know and
maybe I won't I've done things that have
embarrassed me later where I've got a G
I really wish I could have not done that
but at the time I was doing it I did it
better than I thought I could or maybe
better than someone else might have done
it I don't know being your own editor is
tough it's hard just to not fall in love
because we're nothing we want to be like
we want our work to be like we want
people to say you're brilliant but you
know what knowing how to do that knowing
how to look at your own work your own
ideas and be the first one to cut
something right some people say that
that's there's a certain amount of
self-loathing that comes with being an
effective artist and I actually believe
that I assume in any given situation
that I'm the weak link and I like to
surround myself with people that will
insure it that I'm the weak right always
just looking to better people it is a
good bit but if yeah if you've got that
whole thing about confidence I don't
know confidence is up is a slippery fish
and and I think that it has to be
measured out it severe it's like heroin
you can get addicted to it well it's not
like heroin is there heroin I guess you
doesn't actually have any good
attributes the confidence confidence is
a real dangerous thing and and I don't
know that it's always good I know that
people respond to it were attracted to
people who are confident but I think
that deep down knowing where your dark
recesses of unknown is is really really
valuable yes I make any sense no I makes
a lot of sense I mean it's possible I
think of someone like WC Fields or
something who who knows maybe he was an
incredible self critic as well but like
these giant outsized hyper confident
seeming people who also achieve great
things and maybe maybe they just
essentially oh yours and they met care
and that makes me think of some
something else if that clip that you
just showed me
rather than hawk yeah if worsen Wells
had seen
would we have Citizen Kane do you think
that Michelangelo knew that he had the
Sistine Chapel nailed before he went in
there right mm-hmm I don't think that he
did you know in jazz people love to tell
the story about Charlie Parker and the
humiliations that he suffered early in
his career but they'd fought through
that adversity to to become probably the
best jazz saxophone soloist the human
kind has ever known right
the value of failure the value of okay
worsen Welles may not have failed he
actually knocked it out of the park when
he made Citizen Kane but something like
Charlie Parker had to fail miserably
before being able to bounce back to do
something great so if we all live with
this thing of not failing of making sure
you don't fail because oh my gosh it's
depressing well we don't get anything
great out of that yeah I also have to
kind of pick that with a grain of salt
because he's Ethan Huck he's done a lot
of very cool and risky things over the
years and how many of them would you
categorize is great that's a good point
I'm not saying he didn't but I just
asked you to name one and you couldn't
well Dead Poets Society he was very good
enemies he's been a very good actor and
many more all I did all I'm saying is
that I just asked you name one that was
great ray it was five seconds of silence
I'm not saying he isn't great I'm saying
that he's lit he's living a life that
allows him to do a lot of different
things I'm like him in that and I like
think we call that a Renaissance man a
lot of times when somebody just doesn't
want to settle on one thing could he
become the greatest actor of generation
maybe but he's spent a lot of time doing
other things to find out who he is I
admire that greatly the risk aversion
and let's just say that all those
comfortable goals would not work for me
because you know what I would do I would
set
gobs of comfortable goals that would
allow me to simply be comfortable and
confident and that would be boring
and I wouldn't want to even look at me
in the mirror yeah I can become an
excuse or a way of a self-protection but
it hasn't for him it's worked for not
entirely no I mean he's done a million
different he's done a million different
things and and he's been critically
acclaimed for a lot of those things do I
think it's a scale and we all fall in a
slightly different place in the scale
going back to Orson Welles briefly like
he did in fact
fail quite a bit I mean he has some
money although he failed huge but I'm
you mad not until after Citizen Kane
right but Studios pursuing him for lost
hundreds of my gosh I he is one of my
favorite characters of history because
that he's one of the few people that is
genuinely Shakespearean yeah I in his
life the fact that he threw his theater
work during the you know the war project
administration the Mercury Theater and
then moving into Citizen Kane do did a
black Macbeth like in the fact that he
made the set in Haiti that premiered in
Harlem in Geneva I'm a huge fan of that
period and what he did with the Mercury
Theater and all of those people and that
you know that gave him the confidence to
go blundering directly into worsen well
and to Citizen Kane where he admitted I
just didn't know I was breaking rules
but did not know and of course he had a
fantastic Greg Tolin probably quite
possibly the greatest cinematographer
who ever lived made a big difference in
that so he's surrounded in several good
people but then he failed miserably yeah
failed I just a lot I wish Verner Herzog
had been making documentaries win Orson
house was alive and you saw her stop
making a documentary about not about
Citizen Kane but about the Magnificent
Ambersons that would have been a lot a
lot more interesting you know it's funny
time off filmmakers and failures one of
my my favorite films is Apocalypse Now
and I don't love Apocalypse Now so much
because I love Apocalypse Now although
it has moments of greatness
I love Apocalypse Now because Francis
Ford Coppola almost lost his freaking
mind and there's that wonderful scene in
the documentary that his wife um what
Eleanor Coppola made where he's saying I
may kill myself I've got no I've got no
act I've got no page he is out there
with all this money in the jungle going
insane which of course he that great
speech at con when he talked about this
movie wasn't about Vietnam this movie
was Vietnam we went into the jungle with
too much money and lost our minds and
and it's that trip you know it's that
journey it's like what balls hold it off
somehow some would say that he didn't
some would say they did I think it's a
great film I think it's it's great on on
many levels and it's infinitely more
interesting to me than the Godfather
right because it's obvious when you look
closely enough that people really did
almost go
at making this I certainly Martin Sheen
went mad and a heart attack on Sameer
yeah so you know when Coppola was making
Apocalypse Now did he set himself small
achievable goals to get confident I
clearly not the two built you know
massive villages that got blown away by
typhoons and and I think that what that
makes him is a hero and I like heroes
no one ever became a hero answering to
small achievable goals the real
difference in a hero is that a hero sets
goals probably that are insane but
achieves enough of them
right you know achieves enough of them
to then fail beautifully you know
Francis Ford Coppola would not get to
make Apocalypse Now had he not made
Godfather 1 and Godfather too right
massive Academy Awards amazing work not
as exciting to me because he wasn't on
the edge he had the confidence he made
those films he was young he was brash
but he did it surrounded himself with
great people Gordon Wallace jr. another
one of the greatest cinematographers
ever Pacino was so at the top everybody
was at the top of their game but is that
heroic no Apocalypse Now is heroic and
and I think that there's something in
human evolution ever since you know
Greek tragedy we need heroes because we
constantly need to be reminded that the
uncomfortable is achievable and we need
that and that actually is what is the
opposite of depressing is seeing that
somebody can like throw themselves into
the abyss and come out with something
you know and sometimes we fail and
sometimes we make it but you know it's
the great doing of it and so I think
that the small comfortable goals could
get you through on a day-to-day basis
that is a lifetime philosophy man
alright we went on way too long them no
we went all right um let's see what we
have next oh this is cool this would be
interesting this is Alison Gopnik
yeah she was on the podcast she's a
developmental psychologist yeah
from from Berkeley it's on parenting and
what kids need most now are you a parent
I am indeed all right yeah actually what
I am are you yes how many I have one I
have a daughter who's getting ready to
turn 17 Wow
I have one boy he's he's a star at age
17 unimaginable yes and her mom's from
here today yeah yeah we look very close
to each other and we're very close her
mom and I divorced last year so that's
been a bit of an adjustment but very
very into my kid I think she's almost
too smart to talk to me she in college
on her way to college she's on her on
her way she's only a junior in high
school she voluntarily decided to take
the SAT on a lark last year and missed
two questions and it pissed her off
all but two and it didn't count because
she was only in the tenth grade that's
what I'm stuck with for a minute and
she's also like six feet tall and blonde
and beautiful so it's like the world is
her oyster it would seem which is like I
hate her just I love her but I hate her
a little bit too she's the kind of girl
that wouldn't talk to me when I was in
high school all right so parenting isn't
a job it's a relationship is the title
of this Alison Gopnik
one of the problems that we always have
is the kind of culture in which say
children involved is hard to replicate
in our current culture so I always say
sort of ideally what you'd have is a 6
to 1 ratio where you have six grown-ups
taking care of each child and I mean
maybe a better way of putting it is that
you'd have a community of parents you'd
have a community of caregivers the
children are there as part of that
community it's not as if anybody is
sitting there and doing a bunch of
special things that are just directed at
the child so the vision that we have
from school there's someone who's got
this special responsibility of shaping
the education of the child is the vision
that is often imported into being a
parent so there's some special set of
things you should do some you know
flashcards or video or something other
than what you would normally do that's
the thing that you are supposed to do to
educate the child and what the data the
research shows is that children are
learning from just observing and
participating in the everyday things
that people are doing in an incredibly
subtle and powerful way I mean the irony
is that the unconscious things that you
do when you're it when you're
interacting with children are much more
likely to shape and affect the way they
think than any of the things that you
actually consciously decide to do and I
think we have some lovely models for the
way that for example you know my
personal favorite is cooking so my
grandchildren come in and cook with me
now the question is what do we do now to
try to when that's no longer true we're
no longer growing up in a village what
can we do now to kind of recreate that
situation
I'm so surprised when I look at the
world that my daughter Zoe has grown up
in or been raised in compared to the way
that I was raised it concerns me greatly
I was not raised perfectly my father
died when I was 10 I don't have a great
relationship with my mother and I'm a
loner I'm almost incapable of healthy
long term so we're doing despite I was
until my mom started remarrying and then
I had multiple groups of step siblings
but the important thing about about my
upbringing was that although I was born
in Los Angeles my parents very early
moved back to North Georgia where they
were from when I was only seven
and so my summers you know there was a
lot this was back in the days of here's
a sandwich here's your bicycle see you
at dinnertime right and we vanished into
the world and out in that world we
learned certain things we learned that
things would hurt you and there was a
lot of blood and there was a lot of
bandages and they were broken bones but
you learn to negotiate a physical world
in a way that made us self-reliant were
not managed we were not strapped into
five-point harnesses we weren't even
buckled into the backseat we rode around
in the back of pickup trucks we rode on
motorcycles when we were nine it isn't
wonder than any of us survived but it
turned me into a person that I am far
more self-reliant I know how to get
myself around I can be dropped probably
just about anyplace on planet earth and
not dissolve into a puddle of goo my
daughter on the other hand who was
brilliant still can't really find her
way around she drives now but she
doesn't have an interior map because she
was always buckled into a back seat and
strapped in with a DVD player she didn't
observe she got what we gave her what we
attempted to teach her and some of those
lessons took really really well my her
mom and I realized when Zoey was three
that she had actually taught herself how
to read but she wasn't letting us know
because she was afraid we'd stop reading
to her she was already reading faster
than I could by
time she was 6 she had kind of taken
over that way but she was raised in such
a protective way that the only thing
there was no observation really because
every activity was planned nothing just
happened this village concept right
which is so important especially when
you talk about cooking and food
preparation is huge but parents won't
teach their kids or cook around their
kids because they're afraid their
children will be hurt I'm gonna get
burned I'm gonna get cut you know when I
first started teaching my daughter who
is not a big cook how to to cut I put
down a box of band-aids and I said
there's my way in this way and it made a
real impact because visually she knew
what a band-aid box was she knew what
that was going to do but it's funny
because I didn't just have her around
when I was cooking and because cooking
for me was always work it was always R&D
it was always a job you know what she
didn't absorb much of it and she's not
very interested in it she's not yeah I
Justin cook with me I don't cook with my
kid either and I don't know why that
happened either I love to cook I think I
got afraid he was gonna cut him so yeah
so somewhere along the line we got to
where we weren't supposed to let kids
just happen with us in life and let them
see what we were doing
village approach and it all became
presentation it all became we all
started Martha Stewart in our children
well first I've got to make the gravel
and then I'm going to you know make the
air right we're explicit it was
explicitly presented to them instead of
them being allowed to observe it and the
truth is is is there's you know life
doesn't come on flash cards and the
positive lessons that you can give your
child is probably a lot more in your
musician you play music is you just have
your kid around while you play music
you're not trying to teach them music
right you're simply including them in
that activity and I think that they
absorb a heck of a lot more from that
passive teaching which is experiencial
rather than presentational that's right
that's right I know in a lot of I think
what we are what we do communicate to
our children is the anxiety they're the
neuro Smosh legacy so we don't that
we're not trying to I mean even if we
stand there and say you must take risks
and you must have adventure
in your life like so much of what we're
doing is communicating be afraid
well no tellings be afraid I mean and
it's be afraid because I cannot possibly
allow my daughter to walk up the street
to see a friend because 12 pedophiles
will attack her right along that along
that way well guess what there have
always been monsters and I've heard that
in fact statistically that like it we
are mistaken in our belief that that is
increasing even in urban areas paranoia
is not a good parent
paranoia is not a good parent yeah when
I was a kid and I'm 54 the bicycle was
the single most important appliance
because the bicycle was freedom right
although my daughter learned how to ride
a bike it never became a tool of
expression because she was never allowed
to taken anywhere because no place is
safe no place is safe that's right and
that's what we get from from being part
of the tech generation that we're in and
in the internet generation of the the
content generation is that it is not
safe to let a kid do anything I can't
remember when my daughter was first
allowed to walk to a friend's house so
imagine the discovery the self discovery
that she's been robbed of because we
were so busy trying to keep her quote
safe in quo interestingly also when you
think about kind of all the tech tools
and the new cool apps that are supposed
to help us you know and even things like
food delivery services that are supposed
to help us cook and plan meals and so on
everything that we're doing now we're
doing the same kind of explicit
hand-holding and instruction to
ourselves that we're doing through our
kids yeah that is exactly true which
means that basically I have made a
living off of being an opportunistic
parasite okay I have simply jumped in
and filled the gap where parenting
stopped doing it okay you know which is
why my grandmother before she passed
away still could not believe I made TV
shows on a network about cooking she's
like who would want to watch who would
watch that I was like people are gonna
watch that she's like I don't know she
didn't watch it
there's who's on a show with me but she
died oh yes that's right fast she was
first season she did a biscuit show with
me and we had great fun and then she
passed away very soon after that but she
would just shake her head and
she could not imagine a culture where it
would be popular to watch other people
cook yeah we are a culture maybe of
voyeurs in a way well we are yeah most
certainly boyars but we also have a
completely different mindset of what
passes as entertainment for sure and I
mean going back to what we were saying
about the Ethan Hawke video I mean how
are you going to put yourself into
dangerous risk-taking territory if your
entire culture is telling you to sit
back and be so much other people think
things on the Internet
exactly or that we've made our kids so
safe that the idea of risk is it is
alien you can't suddenly turn to
somebody coming out of college with you
having protected them with five-point
harnesses and blah blah blah and say
okay it's time to take a chance well
what the hell is that
what's a chance should we blame the the
attorneys is it is it litigation that's
done there's there's blame enough for
them you know there's there's blame when
when culturally you can't spank a child
anymore because it's perceived as abuse
I I have never spanked my child she
didn't really need it she was more
petrified by having us be ashamed of her
I mean a look would always do it with
her and she never had discipline
problems but I got the crap beat out of
me and sometimes for better and
sometimes it works in a couple of cases
it was proper and right and made an
indelible impression and then the other
times it just pissed me off and was
probably not judiciously and wisely
administered but the truth is is we
don't let each other raise kids anymore
oh we don't have a village we have a
bunch of people pointing fingers at each
other that's right I'll share a story
quickly before we as we wind up I went
to Turkey
my wife is Turkish I didn't know that
yes and I went to visit her the first
time I went to Turkey to visit her we
went near the Mediterranean somewhere a
little town I think it was cosh or
something along the Mediterranean coast
and we went out on a day cruise on one
of these teak boats highly flammable
highly flammable boat would boat
wouldn't boat yeah yeah run by this guy
would obviously been running it for 30
years he goes out on the cruise he opens
a hibachi he takes a hefty
like 1/2 the thick plastic hefty bag
full of charcoal puts it on top of the
hibachi there's like six of us sitting
within one foot of it on the steep hood
he dumps gasoline all over it
any likes it on fire and I was about the
charcoal in the back yeah I love yeah
yeah I love that mastic is smoking and
we're all inhaling the fumes of the UH
the deep book and I'm like Dorothy you
ain't in Kansas anymore no yeah that's
that's he would be shut down
this one's from Wednesday yeah but but
but like in that same country I was able
to wander around these like ancient
caves in Cappadocia without people kind
of telling me not to look or do this or
that you know we were able to rent a
scooter which we couldn't have done in
New York and go travel through the
weight being a wilderness like it was
refreshing I thought yeah but the thing
is you know you're gonna be risk adverse
you have to admit one very simple fact
people die indeed that is the casual
shield you're gonna lose some children
fall to their death kids you know put
their eyes out with BB guns they drown
in the lake scape all drown this happens
and so we've been so except that yeah as
a culture you got to be willing to say
look there will be collateral damage and
there will be little boxes going into
the ground and that's a math that it's
tough for us to do like once you know
people think about that it's you know
100 years ago you had five kids knowing
two wouldn't make it to puberty right
accepted and in some cultures children
are not actually considered human beings
until they reach a certain age oh yeah
because the chances that they're gonna
die is so high that it's better to not
actually think of them as humans their
larval no I'm serious no is it simply
the math is simply against them right
you know and so it's only once they
become 570 I don't want the ages are
these various cultures they're not even
humans yet so you know we either treat
every precious snowflake like it's got
to be protected no matter what to the
potential detriment of everyone else or
somebody's gonna die there are going to
be eyes put out with BB guns
thing interesting these are these are
the trade offs Alton Brown it has been
really great talking to you today thanks
for being on think again really you got
me Sam position you got anything and and
vice versa and that's it for this week's
episode of think again with Alton Brown
do me a favor if you like the show if
you're new to it or if you've been
listening for a while and you haven't
done it yet go on over to iTunes or
Google Play or stitcher or pod capture
or any one of the other 20 million
listening services that you might be
using and rate and or review the show it
means a lot to us and it makes a very
big difference in terms of the
visibility or audibility of the show to
all the people out there in the world I
want more people to hear it and if you
like it I guess maybe you do too next
week we are joined by science writer
James Glick who is here to talk about
surprise things but also his new book
about the history of time travel see you
then